an executive order from President Obama
could help millions pay off their
student loans he announced it today at
the University of Colorado Denver his
plan will let borrowers consolidate
their debt into a single government loan
at a lower rate
[Music]
as the cumulative total of student loan
borrowing approaches one trillion
dollars calls to forgive some or all of
that debt are mounting federally
guaranteed student loans make up more
than half that total and Barack Obama is
pushing to cap the amount any borrower
must pay back in a given year and to
forgive outstanding balances after 20
years among Occupy Wall Street
protesters calls to bail out student
loan holders are arguably the single
most voice demand and sites such as
forgive student loan debt beat the drum
for immediate and widespread relief but
forgiving student loan debt is a very
bad idea for at least three reasons
[Music]
about half of all college students take
out loans and when they do every lender
clearly spells out exactly how much
you're on the hook for and what your
monthly payments are gonna be after you
leave school critics say that eighteen
year olds don't understand what they're
getting into and shouldn't be held
accountable for their decisions but
that's an argument against letting kids
attend college not against letting them
borrow against future earnings to get a
degree that will increase lifetime
earnings by somewhere between about two
hundred and eighty thousand and one
million dollars while the cumulative
total of all college related debt is
huge it's not so big for individuals the
typical college graduate who borrowed
money to attend graduates owing about 25
grand they've got a minimum of 10 years
to pay back that amount and the
repayment schedule can be extended and
modified for a wide variety of reasons
the monthly payment for 25 grand in
student loans at going rates comes to
about 290 dollars a month that's not
chump change
but given that college grads have
unemployment rates that are less than
half the national average and that the
average salary offer for graduating
seniors is almost 50 grand the loan
amount isn't so bad either
I'm opposed to it like Tea Party
activist Occupy Wall Street protesters
are right to rail against bailouts for
big banks and financial institutions
that are politically connected but
student loan forgiveness advocates are
wrong to perpetuate yet another cycle of
balance it's never right to socialize
losses while privatizing games that's
what the banks did they erased their
money on stupid investments and then got
made whole at the expense of taxpayers
student loan forgiveness is simply
another version of the same swindle and
it offloads the cost of other people's
decisions on to taxpayers who guarantee
federally backed student loans College
is an important decision and it's made
even more expensive by heavily
subsidized loans but letting people off
the hook for loans they made with full
knowledge of the cost will not only
dissuade anyone from lending to students
who have no collateral other than their
future work output it will make it that
much harder to argue against the next
call for bailouts from the next group of
special interests for Reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie
you